[Music]
okay everybody so this is my spoiler
review of spencer
this film is directed by pablo loreen
famous for recently doing jackie with
natalie portman and it is written by
steven knight and of course it stars the
wonderful kristen stewart here so
i
was really excited about this film if
you know from my previous reviews
anything i've reviewed with kristen
stewart and i still think she's a
criminally underrated actress and
everything she's been i think she's aces
and this is a really good performance
for her to show what she can actually do
as an actress and of course i was blown
away but i'll get more into the
performance but there's a lot of stuff
going on about this film and i have a
lot of thoughts about it um so i saw it
in theaters last night and it's
interesting so
you know this film i really like the
decisions the cinematographer and
director made and how they shot it what
i really liked was
there's a such a heavy amount of
close-ups here on the character of diana
played by kristen stewart and
what it does is it gives trust into
their lead actress here in her
performance that she can handle having
so many close-ups and that it's all
expressed in her emotions on her face
and she steps up to play and crushes it
in that aspect so choosing to do all
these close-ups with diana really worked
because this film really puts you in the
shoes of diana it is a
movie that you feel like when you leave
you just live the life of somebody else
in just a time span of about two days um
which was really fascinating and was
really effective and honestly throughout
the film
that's the goal is that you're living
through the eyes of diana and that
you're seeing what she went through you
only basically see close-ups of maybe
just the character of her friend maggie
here played by sally hawkins but mostly
everyone else has never shown the
close-up and that's for a reason and
it's deliberate and i think that really
works and
that everyone else is supposed to feel
colder what i love too about the filming
here is that they do a lot of wide shots
where they make diana feel really small
here look really small here and this big
world around her it's this crown that
it's giving you that prison feel of this
huge establishment that she's feeling
trapped in and feeling small at points
and then to come around at the end and
take her power but
i think again the cinematography
excellent um the makeup excellent these
are things that are going to be
definitely considered for oscars uh the
costumes are perfect i mean you look at
pictures diana and look at the outfits
they did here it's spot on so they
really did a great job especially the
with the hair too hair makeup all of it
excellent now i'm a huge huge radiohead
fan it's my favorite band seen them live
a couple times i love when johnny
greenwood does a score he did the score
here that got me really excited i love
the main tune he uses here titled
spencer and it's really played a lot in
this film um it's the one that's played
whenever she's having a moment going
towards her independence and being her
own woman again with her obviously made
a name spencer here but i
was disappointed in the angle they took
whether it was the director's decision
mixed with johnny greenwood's that
they had some moments where they're
doing these wonders following princess
diana in the beginning and they use a
lot of
similar
jazzy
kind of tracks that reminded me of
birdman and too much like birdman i
didn't think that worked here tonally
with the film i thought it was too
similar i didn't like that and i thought
there could have been a little more
variety as well in the score where they
play that spencer theme so much clearly
to repeat it in those moments but i
would love liked
some of the music to stand out a little
from the rest of the music because it's
all so similar and then having this
weird out of tone jazz birdman feel
which i wasn't crazy about so for me
it's one of johnny greenwood's weaker
scores which was disappointing so
script-wise what really worked about
this script by steven knight is that
from the start it's setting up how
they're going to angle this diana story
that you're in
today with her and it's this short time
frame but
it's this story set up about her scene
from the top her father's jacket on that
scarecrow this story is about wanting to
go back home it's about her being a
rebel but it's also wanting a taste of
normal life and
what it does so well is it it's a
miserable film right for the first two
acts you're miserable watching it and
this is where it gets tough to review it
because
the story is
basically putting you in those shoes and
it's a story that really effectively
works and selling you
how you could have a miserable life and
something that people see is this
glamorous life this royal life a lot of
money you're in a castle for god's sake
but this really convinces you oh my god
yeah this is how you can be miserable in
this and feel like you're in prison like
diana and
they pay that off here and
you get your relief in the third act it
does get hopeful you do get that okay
we're getting a win here with diana but
does it take too long to get there i
don't know what worries me is that when
i was in the theater a couple people
walked out right around the end of the
second act until it got to that relief
for the third axon maybe just took a
little too long and i'm also gonna say
those first two acts were just a little
too slow for me i think it needed to
chop a little bit of it out especially
some of the scenes with the kids
um
that maybe they added too much meat here
and it need to get quicker to that
relief because it is so depressing and
that is the point right it's such a
realistic film the way it was just
angled and to feel that depressing
feeling of your main character
and you get the relief so i'm happy you
get that payoff for it and to make it
really hit emotionally which it does
but again maybe it just took a little
too long to get there but i still
thought it was really effective i also
thought the horror aspect worked really
well here especially that first dinner
scene and
how they handled her eating disorder um
i think it really put you in the shoes
well of that and
having that go on a couple times in this
was really powerful and in that theme i
loved about
just her wanting to have a normal life
and her talking about the middle class
and how she loves kids she loves
pheasants right and she's not this
person who's also nudity and wants what
all these other people want with
tradition and that she stands up for
what she believes at the end for her
kids and protecting them in the process
from becoming like their father and this
traditionalist life with shooting these
peasants and i love that they ate kfc at
the end here because that means so much
and
it's them just enjoying a bucket of ksc
even though they could have the nicest
food in the world so
really works well and her in the
drive-through saying her last name was
spencer again breaking free of this
royal family and claiming her
independence again finding that joy and
that love which was earned here
especially with lines with maggie
telling her that that you know screw
even going to a doctor just
have some joy in your life and i'm
running i thought that all worked really
well i do think maybe it took a little
long for maggie to come back where maybe
didn't hit as hard the scenes with
maggie because we hadn't seen her in so
so long
but still really good and they had this
good theme going on too about currency
and how you're basically just currency
in a royal family like that there it's
just soulless you know it is just imager
keeping and how hard it was for her to
have to worry about all these things
about being photographed and there's
moments i thought were really effective
and how they shot it where she goes to
the christmas mass and there's this rack
focus shot i loved where she's looking
at the girl who
had an affair with her husband and then
it cuts between her point of view
looking at her then to her husband then
back to her and that really did a good
job of getting inside of the head of
diana and then going right to a scene
with all these people for photographing
her and she's just trying to have a
normal christmas morning i thought was
brilliant and showed you the horror of
that and
that this storyline going with the book
about she wasn't going to be the woman
in that book who was in a royal family
who had her head chopped off uh in a
similar situation she was in about an
affair
that she was gonna take
charge of her own destiny and my
favorite scene is in the third act when
she sees a vision of that woman in her
old house
and has this like
almost flashing life before her eyes
thinking the suicidal
decision she was about to make going
down the staircase
but has these positive thoughts of when
she was happiest in her life i thought
that was brilliant with the music and
the score everything was perfect there
and
it helped me who's someone who doesn't
know a lot about the princess diana
story in her life so it kind of catches
you up in a way too about you know when
she was married
her growing up her childhood shots of
that of just being happy then and then
being happy with her kids most of kids
and
finally getting back to that happiness
by the end i thought was great and again
props to christian stewart still all
this brilliant stuff but the end of the
day kristen stewart's performance was
perfect she was incredible and it's all
in the eyes with her too but also her
physicality and really showing that the
way princess nana walked everything it
was just a perfect performance to me so
that's the other thing too you can look
at this film as
it's a case where it's more rare where
most films you know start off good and
then get
worse as they go along or this was the
opposite where i felt like it just got
better as it went along um and the third
act was just light years ahead for me
and really brought the score for me
compared to the first two which i
thought were just a little too slow and
you had points you're like okay where is
this going
it's tough too because you look at it
why i'm saying it's hard to review is
like it's so realistic it's so
miserable the first two acts and you
really that's a purpose for that and
that works and i appreciate that but
then there's an argument to be made i
could see too or maybe it didn't even
just a little hollywood put in a little
flavor uh just to keep those people from
walking out let's say the end of the
second act and that'll need a little
more of that maybe
you know stretch things
into believability factor and make it a
little less realistic but i still like
it i like that it went this route so i'm
not saying i agree with that argument
but i can see that argument because yeah
it does get really slowed down and maybe
it's just too freaking miserable like if
you're not in the right mood for this
movie you're not going to like it you
know you got to be ready to just feel
sad for tracks but you get that relief
and that's what i'm happy about you get
the reward and it really pays off
emotionally in the end
in that big moment with her and her kids
so
really awesome stuff there and it stays
with you i haven't seen a film in a
while where i left and i'm thinking
about it and i feel like i watched this
movie and i lived through someone's
shoes for two hours and
really got a new perspective and what it
would be like because you're like oh how
could this person you know so
famous and
all these luscious things in life be so
sad and you see it it it sells it it
made its mission accomplished you know
and
why she would want to go the other way
and you hear of people who have it all
that want to go just have a normal life
you get it from watching this so that
that's to be applauded so again you know
cinematography
uh costume makeup lead performance all
these things gotta be oscar worthy and
especially christian stewart here my god
i hope she is the front runner we'll see
his oscar season comes out she's at
least gotta get nominated or it's gonna
be just a crime if she doesn't and
again i'm going to say the score the
main tune is amazing but there could
have been more here um again i didn't
like the jazzy parts that were very
birdman like just unoriginal to me at
this point and
it could have had a more different
variation of music here and there just a
lot of it sound too similar at some
points but
overall i'm giving this film an 8.9
i would give it higher because it's just
brilliant that third act and has
brilliant themes and so much of this is
just so well done
but
the first two acts were just a little
too slow for my taste and maybe not as
focused um and again maybe the maggie
relationship could have been
done a little better and had more just
maybe a scene or two more with her but
yeah i'm giving it an 8.9
close to a masterpiece close maybe it
was just edited down a little bit pace
picked up a little quicker and again a
little bit better of a score and a
little bit better of a storyline with a
friend i would have really given this a
higher score but 8.9 i think it's still
really great and what i'm gonna take
away from it again is the production
design the costumes the makeup and again
this brilliant lead performance and i
actually love the cinematography too so
uh let me know what you thought of it
down below i'd love to hear your
thoughts if you haven't seen if you plan
on seeing it i read every comment and
try to respond as many as i can please
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
one of my reviews of movies i also do tv
reviews and i also do celebrity
interviews you want to check those out
please follow me at steve barley show on
twitter instagram and tick tock for more
of me and i'll see you next time